When the super rich get really really
rich, it has an impact on you. The rich
getting richer and richer and richer and
ordinary people owning fewer and fewer
assets that affects you because the rich
are competing for the same resources
that you need. There's only a certain
amount of things in the economy, only a
certain amount of housing, only a
certain amount of education,
universities, doctors, dentists,
physical space in the cities. As the
rich get aggressively richer, they start
to consume more stuff and that means
less stuff for you. And the way that you
see that is generally the prices of
things that you buy going up. The rich
are also competing with you for
essentially the ownership of your
politics, your politicians and your
media. If your politicians are getting
paid 100 grand a year, 150 grand a year
by the people and they can also get
paid£10 million a year to work for the
rich. Who do you think the politicians
really work for? And when the rich are
super super super super rich and your
average taxpayer is increasingly poor,
it gets harder and harder and harder for
you to compete with them. You have
basically found yourself in the same
situation that Latin Americans and
Africans have been in for a long period
of time. You cannot compete anymore for
ownership of your politicians with the
super rich. And I think this is this
classic example of why inequality
matters for you.